what is going on there oh God I always do
this I gotta do a koi style citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to continue the
Kung Fu Panda Trilogy with Kung Fu Panda 3
bringing it full circle joined by the man
who just landed in from Rome koi genre show
them the back of your shirt it is appropriate
look at that doesn't he look like a character
look at that right there from the Kung Fu
Panda Universe shirts from Ireland but I flew
near and straight blast is the style of martial
art that I feel like Kung Fu Panda depreciate
that is true I appreciate your words and wisdom
bringing back your coin ladies and Gentlemen
please leave a like on this video that would
mean the world I want to thank you all who
have been on this journey with us this has
been a pleasant surprise for both koi and
I really been having a lot of fun speaking
of fun I want to thank everyone because we
sold a crap ton of shirts for space baby shirt
I showed this for the first time on Kung Fu
Panda 2. it's almost our number one selling
shirt at Zero edition so guys if you want
to get yourself a space baby shirt go to shopzeroedition.com
it's one of the best ways to support the channel
and also one of the best ways to support the
channel is one of the best ways you get an
awesome experience at Kung Fu Panda 3 by joining
our patreon page become a super sexy reject
today once again massive gratitude to all
who have joined because we've been doing so
many movie reactions we've been doing so many
movie reactions that a lot of you have been
joining us over there I could hear the music
for the intro in my head as I'm doing this
one can do it I I can't actually hear right
now it's just funny that my mind just gotta
just left my body for a second but yeah guys
I cover so many things exclusively over their
reaction highlights and watch songs included
I've spoken enough let's go
hey
what
it's so calmly hi old friend
Master Oogway it's a different kind of opening
well now I'm ready for a rematch took you
long enough
I like this music gorgeous
you've grown stronger
[Music] oh Neato I have taken the chi of every
Master here and soon I will have your power
too when will you realize the more you take
the less you have theme
cool
wow with your chi I will finally be able to
return to the mortal world will be there to
stop me oh no I have set another on that path
he dies again what a turtle life then I will
find him and take his G2 so in this world
the chi is like their life force is a soul
too yeah yeah their whole experience what
a chill Zen Turtle even his Chi Justice is
about to be served [Music]
where are they going dinner [Music]
noodles we'll have two Justice platters please
yes served never underestimate the power of
a dramatic entrance I've heard about some
Masters who can win a fight just by throwing
open a door
[Music] before the battle of the Fist comes
the battle of the Mind hence the dramatic
entrance
that is a dramatic entrance my final class
because from now on your training will be
in the hands of the Dragon Warrior oh whoa
me Teach I mean why not tiger She's always
telling to do be quiet po you see what I mean
let me show you another move the dramatic
exit what's that [Laughter] he's gone guys
it's cool we await your instruction master
oh no fire fire stop what are you teaching
them did you at least learn a little something
yes that you can't teach and Tigress is flammable
turns out what were you hoping to teach them
from that what could have occurred
back to square one PO
he said you're a loser that's a great cut
Tigers told me yeah well did she also tell
you that it'll never happen again because
I'm done teaching or being humiliated both
I don't know why you ever thought I could
teach that class you learn a lot from humiliation
winner learn Panda if you only do what you
can do you will never be more than you are
word
oh we can heal
life force restore the chi already water bended
now he's life force bending what was what
was that was G mastering G requires Mastery
of self Oogway sat alone on a cave for 30
years oh how boring you're never gonna be
like you I'm trying to turn you into you study
practice teach is that a discipline yeah
[Music]
I love the music that you compose for this
guy yeah it's a little zestier general Kai
Supreme warlord of all China Jade slee is
the Beast of Vengeance JK Simmons yeah I just
heard it
bring them to me oh my God he can control
the Masters like Shazam with the sins well
Shifu says I don't know what it means to be
the Dragon Warrior now I have to be a teacher
Kung Fu that's a promotion I take the caption
oh Mrs Chow always wins that it's good [Laughter]
the cutaways are solid
[Music]
oh my God his dad is this how he meet his
dad or someone related him who are you sir
it's Brian Cranston yeah last time it was
Jack Black though remember he voiced himself
yeah
very sorry thank you I hope you find yourself
put it together I hope you find you a father
the first Panda they've seen
I can't believe you're alive
oh no oh see little Lotus was the name you
were given at Birth oh Dad come say hi to
um I don't know what I'm supposed to call
you I'm pretty sure he said his name is Lee
that was great
if we're taking a picture together huh I taught
Poe was the only Panda left there's a whole
bunch of us where a secret a secret panda
you're flying rhinos battle armor I wonder
if I could fit in that get out of my head
Dad I've wondered the same thing if I could
fit in if you could know if I could fix it
what this does I should pull it [Music] oh
my God it's a Mecca suit
go along son wow I wasn't ready coming back
at you guys
ouch you guys are gonna destroy this whole
King the whole Temple oh
Joe oh yeah [Music]
[Applause]
oh my God dad say hi to my friends that's
cute that they were like monkey brain they're
willing to ignore all the destruction yeah
yeah Dad's here that's matters the Valley's
under attack under attack this is perfect
now you can see what being the dragon Warrior's
all about how's it going to catch up there
to the fight in time and then the armor enemies
of Justice I think what are you kidding me
what's the deal with the green guys some kind
of Jade zombies the master Badger twins with
their crushing double gong technique that
guy is
porcupine arrows
I blinked let's get another one watch out
to do
power up Ah that's cool gotcha
teamwork and food
is he talking about which one they're all
talking we should try that too maybe back
at them okay but we got a plan we're gonna
say first otherwise it won't be scary it'll
just be stupid
it's me talking through that time
was that guy Kai not never never I
like that the other two are legends that he's
like trying to be important to know what else
do I do who he is long ago I had a brother
we had a brother in arms in arms sorry he
says I was an ambitious young Warrior leading
a great Army now here we go finally the animation
opening animation one day we were ambushed
I was badly wounded my friend carried me for
days oh he was caring until we came to a secret
village high in the mountains an ancient place
of healing pandas oh healing who used the
power of chi to heal me oh my God he was destined
oh it's within Poe the yin yang of black and
white Bears I wanted the power all to himself
he saw that what could be given could also
be taken is that a thing like pandas are balanced
because they're black and white is that a
thing we'll look it up all right I banished
Kai to the spirit realm he can only be stopped
by a true master of chi damn green like you
me I can barely make a flower bloom I need
at least 30. does he know how to do that
but he probably hasn't suppressed it due to
the trauma from being ambushed and he's gonna
find himself on the same Journey oh there
it is never mind okay we were waiting immediately
wrong I got you I'm dead it's not that story
you can't take power away from me this guy
can only be stopped by Master of chi I'm a
panda I'll pack your lunch for the road this
dad has just been getting neglected every
move every film left behind every film you
are going to find out where Kai is follow
the trail of those Jake creatures but do not
engage and take mantis what oh man is it because
I yes hahaha this sounds weird to say because
it's an animated franchise for families way
younger feels the most kid-friendly all the
jokes are like for kids and all of it is very
like telegraphed yeah but it's still fun still
fun it's still fun and beautiful way young
but it does feel like more younger yeah I've
been thinking that you don't need to ask me
twice dad yes Dad yes I do think Brian Cranston
is perfect casting for the tattoo paternal
snarky here
my son hates stairs so go home Amanda's we
don't do stairs I've waited my whole life
to hear those words
oh it is not illustrious what's going on here
Doom and Gloom now you can whoa whoa whoa
po oh there it is there it is just Misty Shangri-La
Panda Shangri po pangrila pangrila
oh
[Music]
maybe try Rolling On Your Side not good at
panding
New Chopsticks they're for picking up dumplings
[Music]
[Laughter] its own hand
it's gonna fall in love what about Tigress
why does she keep staring at me like that
try to keep up
Amy Schumer I was wondering if that's her
because I was getting Rebel Wilson Amy Schumer
vibe
yeah but you just figure out the chi [__]
you know I mean saving the world maybe a priority
but it has to know himself
imbecile you're seriously afraid even Master
chickens going in there and he's a chicken
they're like Donkey Kong characters hahaha
I'm going in mantis we have orders we need
our help come on taking her cheek
s
oh
crap we lost Rogan
nice strong just like your the bug Matt
one inch flick got skadooshed I'm ready for
my first day of panda training the panda sleep
till past noon so lesson number one is go
back to bed of course
nobody said this was gonna be easy
I feel like Bryan cranston's doing a John
Goodman impression oh yeah I could call lunchtime
[Music]
oh my God you're gonna need to learn to roll
for the final fight it's gonna be part of
it
[Music] oh what are you doing there
oh
frustrating feeling relaxed totally just let
yourself fall into it got it
[Music] subtle po very subtle oh an entanglement
[Applause]
so you just had a great time it's just living
life that's Panda life just happiness the
opposite of his training in the first movie
is to learn to relax and sleep in to find
himself where's mom or she died she died in
the actual thing that we thought he died in
it yeah when do you think I'll be ready ready
you know to learn how to master Chi soon real
soon come on I want to show you something
else I just wanted to spend time with us he
manipulated him your mama couldn't hold you
still you nearly ate the paper
she was the love of my life and then along
you came my little Lotus low not Lee and low
[Music] okay so she was just part of the genocide
you don't have to worry about losing me ever
again
but a dragon warrior you gotta go fight there
bro great mantis still nothing oh wait it's
them oh
hi this plot feels very anime I like it a
lot of what he can do this might have the
best score I will destroy it anything he has
created
cool always cool the fights are still great
though man yeah
who knocked some Chi out of them
will not let you destroy your grace memory
oh
sorry sorry actually feels like Jackie Chan
gotta do some Voice works for me he actually
showed up today
great shot
oh no it's exactly our fight with Seth Rogen
and Jackie Chan what happened to
[Music] my God [Music]
man I will show you the true power of
great shot though oh with his own statue guys
we all have to move to the secret village
now it's the only place we can live
[Music] damn that's a beautiful destruction
always be someone to who the panda he will
meet the same fate no you can't take on all
the pandas it's funny you could kind of interchange
JK Simmons and Brian Cranston oh yeah yeah
I wonder how often they go up against each
other for Gravelly dad especially on voice
voice over work they could do either roll
yeah I wonder if after life Chi is different
than in life Chi it's probably more peaceful
maybe unless you got some [__] showing
up trying to take it away from him he's got
that necklace I wonder if it's a different
spot because all the all the in-life cheese
seems to be around the waist he's taken every
master in China including Shifu and the others
it's it's all gone po everything everyone
everyone everyone
the bunnies the pigs all been slaughtered
it's a good thing daddy tagged along everyone
else is murdered I don't have more time I
need to learn it now sorry you're not ready
I am totally at one with my panda Parks now
why won't you cause I don't know it son of
a [__] Heisenberg done messed up your
dead wife would be a shame
oh [__] I am not going to lose you again
[Music] not how it works you just did yeah
don't lie to you kid
whoa this just got really dramatic wow everyone's
dead I like it
don't enjoy being right about everything [Laughter]
amazing I can't hear it [Music] oh he may
be a monster but he's still your father
he's so much funnier yeah he's great and he's
always been supportive like a good dad yep
[Music]
third act montage heard you still pull from
me but I realize having you impose life doesn't
mean less for me it means more for Paul um
I lied to him I lied to him for 20 years
sometimes we do the wrong things for the right
reasons that's what I say every time you get
caught he's gotta you know he's gotta try
to do it for the right reason navigate that
that's why I stole from you he still has to
save the world he needs both his dad oh family
Jesse [Music]
really should be working on the Tai Chi the
chi element there we go there we go come on
Tigress I've seen what he can do but he hasn't
seen what I can do the whooshie finger hold
it's my best move I just have to get to Kai
grab his finger and then skadoosh he can only
be stopped by a master of chi oh you sound
just like Shifu with the cheat cheat [Laughter]
unless you had an army of your own
that's right a bunch of rolling Panda all
the pandas have to come together all of us
all through this slump and exhaustion from
walking into that's all they got you don't
even know Kung Fu then you will teach us I
can't teach you Kung Fu I could
oh it was good we can learn Kung Fu we can
be just like you yes we can no that's what
Shifu meant I don't have to turn you into
me I have to turn you into you yeah exactly
get your chiability back your real strength
comes from being the best you you can be so
who are you what do you love what makes you
you this is classic training a whole village
who's about to be attacked very classic and
I know the rolling's gonna come into play
hug that log like it's the last time you're
ever gonna hug it goodbye forever and a little
more to the left this time you can do it I
literally faded into this animation it's so
epic they're doing like Panda stuff it's like
playing with its own Trope yeah [Music] I
love this backstory there is a lot I love
about it though I don't I can't [__] either
yeah there's a lot I do love about it it's
really coming together in the third act for
me yeah now try it with these ah
ah this is clever embracing who you are so
pretty
oh they are ready
amazing
while the cookie Squadron will take position
here now on my signal the two squadrons will
the important thing to remember is that this
is the spot where
if you only remember one thing it's distracted
zombies until I get close enough to put a
wooshy finger hold on pie jumps
I wish I could have taught you this son it's
okay dad remember who you are
[Music] that's what I call a dramatic entrance
hahaha [Laughter]
he's like exposed so so good finally thank
you almost makes me want to spare your life
oh you want to spare me you spare me that
[__] chat [Laughter] [Music]
oh [__] cool you guys have all been turned
green except for you mantis you were already
green
dumpling Squad [Music]
spring roll Squad time for some takeout
nicely done
Danger [Music] oh my God an actual nunchuck
fight yeah
[Music]
it's like what Jackie Chan protects an antique
yeah Master Shifu wait do you have to fight
the turtle
I can and so can I double dare defense
let's finish this
yeah
I didn't even see the roll coming
[Music]
gotta send you back to the spirit Realm skadoosh
it only works on Mortals and I am a spirit
Warrior
no there's no bueno oh
save him with your Chi Papa remember the chi
Palmer save him everyone use your Chi if you
really thought you could send me back to this
the spirit Realm
what are you thinking he doesn't have to send
him there he's gotta make him mortal and then
but I can take you there what's that oh oh
shh didn't see that coming oh damn [Music]
oh the greatest sacrifice skadooshing yourself
skeducing yourself can have multiple meanings
it really can you brought me back don't play
me I tried to finish this in the regular round
suck it in man
how
[Music]
no poop dad remembers your tree we have to
help him we can do this
just follow your heart you told us who we
were meant to be a father oh a friend a dumpling
kicker chick
y baby family oh [Music]
oh that is beautiful
[Music] Epic
oh [__] yeah he's super saiyan Panda now
who are you I've been asking the same question
I am Ray Skywalker the son of a goose student
a teacher I'm all of them
that's awesome oh it's full circle I am the
Dragon Warrior beautiful cool see the giant
dragon you're ready to feel the Thunder this
is awesome wow [Music]
[Music]
[Music] oh my heads up
[Music] ouch
you want my cheese so bad then take it
yes the power is mine implode him like Neo
and agent Smith yeah from the inside breaks
the code [Music]
secret Village Ain't So secret yeah [Music]
you are extra shiny and are you I know right
it's like the best Cape ever when I run with
it then it looks really cool [Laughter] gotta
lay off the Panda Buffet grown up
I hope you would when I sent the message to
your father oh I love the cherry blossom imagery
and all these I saw the future kung fu and
the pears I saw the panda who could unite
them both that is why I chose you Poe this
is good tethering to the first one yeah my
true successor I can't take that just take
it I have a bigger one
there's you who must decide whether to stay
or go I can go back who knows I've never tried
so Zen
like The Legend of Korra
wait where did you get that just dawned on
me that it did teach the village yeah I think
I mastered G oh
can you teach me oh now he's the teacher
oh they've combined forces Everybody Was Kung
Fu Fighting [Music]
we are all Poe [Music]
so they do in Christian churches Palm stuff
foreign
oh my God they've healed everything super
bloom oh ultimate Chi
and while that really does feel like a an
ending yeah like that does a beautiful resolution
of a trilogy I I wonder what the fourth one
would be uh well the first one is about discovering
his inner warrior second one was about believing
in himself third was about discovering himself
the next one is about discovering another
well the third one was about was I mean all
three are essentially his journey of identifying
himself but but like different versions of
himself right yeah yeah and then this is where
he comes into his full self in his third one
it's like it's a great Arc way off way off
blonde yeah that's true guest blondes who
do we know as like overweight comedic actresses
that voice definitely sounded like yeah it's
Ali ABC over yeah I love that Jackie Chan
got to play because like it felt like a waste
a lot to not have him Jackie Chan he actually
got to do some stuff uh but I think it's a
great uh I I think regardless of where this
would stand because I still there's still
a lot about it that I loved and like the last
half of this like definitely I thought it
really helped improve the experience so much
because I would still put this as third out
of the three same but I still really I there's
I I loved like the last half a lot especially
the last like 20 30 minutes it's one of the
best recoveries I've ever seen yeah like because
in the first half I'm not gonna lie two and
a half maybe out of five yeah last half four
I think it lands at a three and a half yeah
I thought it got a lot better as it went it's
like while that first half had definitely
had some moments that were still like fun
and enjoyable it felt very young yeah it was
it was an interesting experience to have one
it is a family movie yet it it seemed the
especially the second one seemed to mature
a lot more and then to regress and I'm wondering
how much that was Fox wanting to be more marketable
because DreamWorks I think of as more story
driven and having elements that the story
is first yeah and then like I don't think
of fox animation much I think of Sony I think
of universal DreamWorks and I think a Disney
with Pixar so I'm wondering if they were like
we got to make it marketable and I also wonder
too what they because this came out a few
years apart from the second one because I
think the second one actually wasn't a huge
hit when it came out and then it eventually
garnered like its audience that it needed
to to warn the third one if I'm not I could
be wrong about that but I'm pretty sure someone
did mention that to me okay so there could
be a trajectory there it's crazy that it ended
with a cliffhanger and they were like maybe
yeah but still I I what I what I really respect
about this is that if the third one still
feels like a central viewing yeah with its
context because it is the complete story it
does feel like it completes the entire story
regardless it reminds me of the future sure
where the first two are amazing and the third
one the second half is amazing it ties all
together no no it's great but you know what
I mean the first half of the third one is
not as strong as the first two to me yeah
yeah and then like it but it's all one story
yeah and I think having it be like one complete
story that's why I was wondering like what
would your fourth one be I assume if he's
become the teacher and like that's the ultimate
of like teacher Master The Apprentice he would
have to pass along the the dragon warrior-ness
like maybe as a kid maybe he like he he you
know is the he's the red panda roll oh my
God I should have said it out loud I thought
the big Panda was Wayne Knight I was thinking
that you was Pax Jolie Pitt little Brad Pitt
Angelina Jolie kid then they were doing the
whole thing about children I was wondering
if they actually got the kids in there I love
it yeah I was wondering if those are the actual
you should have said I had two thoughts that
I did not expressed that I was going I wonder
if those are actually the kids and yeah it
was [__] because you did so much casting
in the first one you were like maybe not this
time and then whenever I guess something out
loud I tended to be wrong yeah and then now
it's on records Because the Internet yeah
uh that was an incredible second half and
uh I was really worried the first half because
I really wanted to love it and then I found
myself being like the beauty of really good
animation is it's all ages and like all ages
isn't the same as y a like all ages is truly
parents can watch it with their kids and get
different experiences but the first half felt
like not all ages and then they found this
amazing shift when suddenly the jokes got
funnier for all ages the world felt more like
it trusted the audience like that was a really
special Trilogy like this is one of the great
trilogies I I truly think that was by the
end I get why this is so beloved yeah it recaptures
that beauty and wonder because yeah a lot
of the humor it had that effect that you might
hear what a lot of people say with like Marvel
movies where they wouldn't just let like certain
scenes just settle with like a dramatic moment
or a little bit of tension there had to be
like a joke you could feel like that script
note of like get a joke in there all the time
get a joke and while the first two are also
really really funny movies the it never felt
like the jokes would undercut a moment and
I would actually feel that in the first half
of this film and and with this villain too
while I love the animation style what they
did and the way they like Illustrated everything
with his I don't know what the names of the
weapons are but those flies yeah those are
great those are amazing uh I thought it was
really cool and while he ought to have been
the most threatening villain because of the
way this movie was paced and how they would
flesh out the scenes with him he kind of just
felt generic which is weird because you got
JK Simmons you've got all these like subplots
with the other Warriors you've got all the
elements but it never landed for me and it
felt like they the context could have lent
itself to something that did feel really like
Primal and personal especially with the history
of what he has he should have felt like the
biggest threat and yet it didn't quite amount
to that I didn't really feel any sense of
true threat until until he was with Poe and
the skadoosh didn't work I was like oh okay
here we are but then lasted just like yeah
and then it's over because well I love the
music around him and while I thought the animation
around like the fight scenes I still thought
they did an excellent job at I still think
the fights were incredible to look at the
animation was just as great and I love Brian
Cranston as the dad I think he was like perfect
casting yeah I love the dad's element I really
like that uh they kept the love of cinematography
and they kept the love of fighting but they
enhanced like the textures like the fur looked
better and better the lighting was obviously
stunning I love the Montage of learning to
be pandas of yourself in that incredibly like
intense visual but it's like eating I really
liked those comedic elements but it took a
while to get to the point where it felt like
the audience was trusted to let it be that
and I definitely think the score was the best
in this one but the first half was a struggle
but I do think it's all worth it by the time
it lands like the the elements that we talked
about with the trilogy trusting itself there
should have been more of he's becoming the
master and he has to fight all the other Masters
he has to find himself after thinking he's
already found himself his dad asked to you
know discover all these things and that's
a great juxtaposition with the villain but
it it definitely felt like they they were
you know hands off a little like sugar coating
it a little bit a little bit but then it got
there yeah and I think the lesson learned
about who we identify as it was great because
that is what makes everyone unique is the
experience that we all have like that everyone
is unique due to the fact that no individual
can have the exact same life experiences one-to-one
ratio right as you and so that's why I always
say unique starts with the letter U it's so
to find out who your unique self is that is
all through the experiences that you uh accumulate
over time and that forms your identity and
I love that by the end of it all that's what
that is what he is embracing is his entire
past and instead of trying to conform to something
he is accepting of all so I thought that lesson
is actually beautiful I didn't even see the
arcs are usually pretty telegraphed yeah this
one was like I didn't actually predict that's
where he would land and I thought that was
a really poignant way to go about with his
character Arc there that does encompass the
entire Trilogy as well like it not only does
it for this film but the entire Trilogy I
always say the best Series have the 3x structure
per film and then there's also this incredible
3x structure I usually since most people follow
me for Marvel reference the Captain America
Iron Man Thor those three arcs and how they
kind of like you know mix with each other
like selfless to selfish with Captain American
and Iron Man and then Thor is beautifully
just like trying to figure out self but all
of those are individual movie arcs and then
there's this overarching Arc I'm so impressed
that this film is every single Kung Fu Panda
is him discovering who he is and there's still
more to discover of who you are and then the
third one is like a nine act structure because
you've got the three acts in each of the films
and there's this beautiful overarching self
of all of who you are yeah and I love that
like you're saying The Who I Am is individual
to me because whenever I talk about favorite
movies and things people get so angry at the
specificity but it's it's no one has lived
even a twin is going to be different than
a twin you lived differently and I love that
the movie found a way to embrace that while
getting young two old people to just accept
who they are I think it's a really important
film it's an important message too because
I think people struggle with their identity
a lot yeah it's kind of like an ongoing thing
of self-discovery so I think doing three movies
about self-discovery also justifies its per
its sequels it's the same yeah I think I felt
that every time as opposed to just doing something
that's plot Centric because yeah even though
like it's part of the execution of the first
half wasn't 100 working for me the I didn't
feel like this plot wasn't necessary to tell
like it felt like a necessary story to it
that's really interesting even when I wasn't
invested as much as I felt I wanted to be
I was still happy to be here and I was still
like I'm glad they made this and I kept thinking
like there's a new audience for this and that
made me happy every time I felt myself drift
but I kept coming back yeah and the way they
did resolve the whole thing with the dads
I thought was kind of a unique angle to have
as well and I love the way that came together
I thought Goose dad was the funniest he's
ever been oh he was excellent and I love that
Tigris is still mysterious but like we get
a little bit more for every time I wish she
my only note is I wanted a little bit more
her because of where we left off in two yeah
but I feel like her backstory is a little
dark for what they were telling here and I'm
hoping in four we get some like Tigress like
maybe that's how we get a protege maybe there's
a little tigers maybe there's a little Panda
tiger baby you know what I noticed is there's
never been a romance not a single one and
I think that's really cool how they did not
they've never leaned on that you saw dungeons
dragons right yeah I love the fact that the
relationship between this isn't a spoiler
it's just they established at the very beginning
yeah but uh the Chris Pine and Michelle Rodriguez
is platonic and I love that they didn't make
it uh like 90s action movie plot yeah I thought
they were gonna have him fall in love with
uh Kate Hudson I thought they were gonna have
a follow-up with uh her uh but that is not
the case at all I really really enjoyed the
second half I wonder if in the next one they
introduced western civilization and then posed
dad gets shot oh and turned into soup and
then oh which dad I thought the goose
I
also love that they didn't get rid of the
mom as a subplot but they also let it be about
the dads without it feeling like the the generic
jealousy was only serving the actual narrative
it didn't become like so much that it underwrote
either character yeah because it could have
become that it could have been the whole movie
a lesser movie would have been like the fighting
dads yeah yeah and I love when they suited
up with the thing they set up at the Rhino
suit in the beginning there were so many great
callbacks to not just the first film but this
film again like a 9x structure yeah yeah I
think I think there was some potential that
they could have definitely uh leaned in on
that could have made more of an impact uh
not just with his main villain because JK
Simmons is great casting it's cool to have
him here because I mean I've seen all Legend
of Korra and there's a lot of elements Legend
of course the sequel to Avatar got it and
um so it's like the Avatar religion horror
world and uh JK Simmons is one of the main
characters in Legend of Korra but he's like
the nice Mentor guy yeah he's a sweetheart
so he could have easily played the Brian Cranston
part yeah Brian krantzen easily could have
played the JK that's why I was like listening
it's kind of funny they could have just switched
them up if they wanted to um so it's cool
seeing him here and there were so much references
like especially with like the spirit world
and the animals that were really making me
uh look back on it and there was a lot of
like anime plot points but I did think even
the jaded it's like the way they introduced
things that it the threat was never really
felt and I think that's part of what was missing
here was the villains in the first two whenever
you cut to them even Gary oldman's uh Peak
[__] one was funny at times but also very
menacing and I think that Menace intention
when you were around them was very much absent
when you were here with them and to go from
villains that became progressively more interesting
to something that felt like uh we got to get
the outline out of the way of what their backstory
is and just kind of go by nowhere I was missing
a little subtext and even the jaded I thought
you know like every main bad guy has their
henchmen sure except for the first guy with
it but uh you know having their henchmen and
having the jaded Chi Spirits these are Masters
at your disposal and I really thought that
they could would have made that even more
threatening and actually had some actual Stakes
when you're fighting them but it always felt
like no they got those guys handled yeah it's
just the main bowl that you got to worry about
and so I thought that was a missed opportunity
and the other main missed opportunity with
character that I thought they really could
have done and maybe there's a line in here
or something that completely flew over my
head uh because yeah I understand the dad
wanting to protect his son and take him away
uh panadette Brian Cranston want to take them
away uh however he knows like I thought there
could have been a little bit more Triumph
of the of the of the panda Spirit perhaps
with the trauma that he went through with
what happened with the village before and
losing his mom and then this is a big part
of what he has to overcome acceptance of that
being a part of his life like like in the
first film like trauma was part of him accepting
himself yeah and then like Poe could have
helped teach him about that along the way
and and that's a that could be a big part
of what leaned into his decision to lie to
Poe yeah to get him out of there and maybe
that's a bit of a cliche I I know feel like
you just would have been sometimes it's cliche
you serve story I feel like it would help
this add the because some a lot of times when
this movie started like clicking better was
when they allowed themselves to get a little
dark or get a little dramatic yeah the second
half yeah and like the cliche I wanted was
the idea that accepting yourself is so important
right like this film all three of them but
especially this one was about accepting all
the parts of you I really wanted there to
be a bit of a play on like if you're jaded
you don't believe in yourself like I thought
the jail oh yeah I would have played with
the word play of like the Masters being jaded
and him having to not be jaded about who he
is like if you've literally got a punt right
there and I I just felt like the not only
is he becoming a master he's fighting jaded
Masters and he has to accept himself like
there was just a few levels of subtext I wanted
yeah still a B plus because of the second
half but the other two are A's for me and
the second borders on a plus yeah and I thought
the spirit world was beautiful too stunning
stunning spirit world I love this but it took
it to the second half yeah yeah it is interesting
I've never seen a sequel be so like oh no
I don't to love this more oh I'm back yeah
yeah it is interesting how it brings that
love back but yeah that it is just the first
half that it is a bit of it's not even like
a slog or something like that no we just I
noticed we both kept our body language hippie
and like is it gonna get is it gonna get is
it gonna get Kung Fu Panda if we're just waiting
for it to reach the heights that the predecessors
uh were able to and it would have been rough
patent yeah and and eventually I I think I
think the biggest Saving Grace is the fact
that this story does feel essential to complete
the package I love them and I'll definitely
be showing my kids and I'll definitely like
revisit this on my own I might even re-watched
them in the next two years for like Kung Fu
Panda 4. does it Fork around is it next year
or two years I assumed two years because they
just like locked it all in that's pretty animation
but they could have been like we've been working
out for 10 years I hope I mean they got the
rider strike happening too so I hope it's
written yeah I hope it's done and the animators
just took time to animate you can't just really
rewrite a bunch when you're having doing a
whole big animation movie when you've got
Seth Rogan to people like that you can't assume
it's written all the way either like you've
got to have that be flexible oh I wonder what
they'll do it is it is fascinating because
I feel like the story is complete that I'm
like what would you do with the fourth one
writers are so malleable if if you have a
if you think of something that's hereditary
that's why I'm thinking it's this kid I think
it's him passing on the the mantle because
the time that is also passed is interesting
um and I feel like fourths are often like
the next of the warrior let's lead the weapon
four yeah you bring in Chris uh hand down
the franchise and then it comes back 25 years
later
we're here for your Lethal Weapon references
all day all day Lethal Weapon five directed
by Mel Gibson coming 2027. I know I can't
wait it's gonna be dark is finally gonna die
oh Riggs is supposed to have died every time
Mel's gonna finally kill Riggs gonna be the
the uh the most violent one two 100 I just
wonder if Mel cups can get that tone down
what do we uh what are we checking um I wanted
us to see when Kung Fu Panda okay and then
uh I wanted to do a patreon the day shout
out and then after that good time for me to
pee okay again I gotta pick what is wrong
with you all right I'll keep them I'll keep
them company trying to drink a gallon a day
I think he had a gown before he showed up
this is sick problem yeah it's coming in 2024.
that's what it says here guys acting like
an idiot What's this called Kung Fu Panda
Legends of Awesomeness nah that's not the
same thing that's a completely different thing
is it oh there's a show hey is this show good
oh my God what the show ref is around for
2011 to 2016. is this a well-regarded series
can you guys comment because I'm realizing
right now that this is a one-way conversation
because I am recording this prior to you being
able to actually listen to what I'm saying
Kung Fu Panda Legends just killing the time
easily could have just cut this out of the
video but instead I decided to just be here
stay on camera in hopes that Coy would get
back here in time for me to finish talking
it's not coming up on here Kung Fu Panda Legends
of Awesomeness here we go let's type this
in 73 audience score oh and Lucy Lou did do
the voice like she came back for that well
there's a lot of episodes there's Mike Winger
do we like him as Poe he can't replace Jack
Black who's his mic Winger's guy a mick Winger
got his name wrong yeah he was Bill All His
Highest on Rotten Tomatoes the law and new
breed of hero he could do better
um what else has it done oh he voices Iron
Man and Marvel's Avengers is he doing like
a Jack Black impression I imagine what he's
doing is a Jack Black imagine what is Kung
Fu Panda the pause of Destiny what are these
other things do people like these other things
I don't know fascinating stuff but yeah I
kind of wanted a little bit more of Kate Hudson
as well I thought that she was an interesting
character to have there and Brian Cranston
he does you know a lot of us do associate
himself what's great is like he's got the
two characters of um Hal from Malcolm in the
Middle and he's also got you know um Walter
White from Breaking Bad so it's cool to see
a little bit more of that Hal side come out
of him anyway at one point I don't know if
he's gonna get that reference comes out of
2024 let's do a patron of the day shout out
just could have done it while you were gone
I was surprised you didn't did you just made
up about a movie that's out in a year yeah
I was looking up these things called Kung
Fu Panda the pause of Destiny and Kung Fu
Panda the show that Ranford like seven years
Legends of Awesomeness was it Jack Black no
it's some guy named Mick Wingard I don't know
what the hell he's done wow good for him Lucy
Luke came back and said James Hong wow uh
is there we usually check Rotten Tomatoes
scores while we're here yeah fun I mean it's
a tradition yeah we could this is what the
people want I could have done it earlier I
mean could have people are here for the long
game all right 86. that's still pretty good
solid 79 audiences about how I feel I think
I think it landed at like a B plus yeah that's
like actually that's more like a c but uh
yeah no no no that's fine uh so this is the
lowest rated one how to do box office um I
mean enough to warn a Kung Fu Panda 4 and
how long ago was that 2016. okay seven years
yeah it's gonna be a kid you think so I think
it's gonna be like Young Avengers everything's
we've all become parents all right let's see
let's look at Kung Fu Panda 2 first okay two
maybe oh that's a great internet a half a
billion dollars internationally 75 of the
box office International wow yeah that's a
great International 666 total that's bananas
money um so yeah this wait which this one
dropped off yeah this one dropped off by a
little bit Yeah a good amount actually like
a hundred and thirty thousand of the thirty
thousand years 130 million dollars it uh dropped
off by still a big International Market but
uh both both dropped domestic and international
yeah yeah but still half a billion dollar
movie weren't in the fourth one I mean this
really didn't feel as big either it didn't
it didn't I think the villain issue I think
the fact that it leaned younger five million
dollars cheaper to make and it shows every
frame every million dollar that feels cheap
where was it I can see it on screen I'm also
fascinated by the fox Dream Work combo at
all that's really interesting to me like the
studio element they ruined it yep Fox came
in just caught they don't even exist anymore
they do they're at Disney patron of the day
Shadow what'd you guys think of the movie
leave your thoughts down below is this your
favorite where would you rank it I know there's
some people I know our audience someone comes
in and goes I don't know it's my favorite
It's usually the top comment happy for him
good for them I'm not uh two one three for
me uh yeah that's my exact rating it's pretty
it's pretty obvious about halfway through
it was like two and three but then I got better
still though still two on three yeah but that's
uh it's still a good movie that's still a
great Trilogy I put this in the top 10 trilogies
it stuck The Landing more than a lot of thirds
do right about Terminator three right above
Return of the King I mean obviously um hold
on I'm looking for my list guardians of my
top five trilogies now all right koi say patron
of the day shout out uh patron of the day
shout out I want to shout out the great the
one the only Everett pixel might Baker because
your name has a parenthesis with a cool moniker
in the middle of it and I feel like that makes
you exciting also your last name Baker probably
over the years was originally had a baker
in your family and they kept that name like
the Smiths that were blacksmiths I think it's
cool when the last name is from the before
times when we just Mound people we were like
hey you do this job you're a thatcher like
in the night's tale like William Thatcher
his father was a man who made roofs and he's
the son of that man I like when a name is
strong and mighty and about what your ancestors
did for a living do you bake I hope so we
appreciate you being a patron well done that's
how you shout out I'm just gonna have you
record all these in advance the makeup stuff
about every neighborhood history like here's
coin doing the Patriots I can't wait to see
you all right enjoy that bacon thank you thank
you you guys for be here we'll see you guys
soon foreign